[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ses points de vue et
c'est en direct bien sûr comme chaque
soir à la même heure avec deux invités
bonsoir claire chartier vous êtes la
rédactrice en chef des pages idées de
l'express l'express qui vous propose en
couverture ce week end le piège de
l'addiction
alors ça n'est pas un dossier spécial
sur le vin rouge ou le chichon mais sur
l'argent public qui y coule à flots
large en hélicoptère comme disent les
économistes qui se déverse sur toutes
nos économies bonsoir gabriel cluzel
vous êtes
rédactrice en chef du site boulevard
voltaire vous êtes aussi essayiste votre
dernier livre nous sommes tous d
héritier a été publiée aux éditions
artège je propose de commencer par
parler du désormais célèbre conseil
scientifique théoriquement il ya un
gouvernement dans ce pays avec un
premier ministre
on se demande parfois si c'est pas
monsieur delfraissy le professeur
delfraissy et ses acolytes qui en fait
sont nos vrais patrons regardez ce qui
s'est passé lundi dernier jean castex a
annoncé que finalement c'est pas la
peine d'envoyer les enfants à l'école
jeudi et vendredi que les vacances
pouvaient commencer plus tôt parce que
c'était ville et du conseil scientifique
et qui l'a trouvé très bonne autres
éléments apportés au dossier jean
françois delfraissy donne ce matin une
interview à nos confrères du parisien
et il explique en gros qu'on en prend
encore pour six mois que l'arrivée des
vaccins n'aura pas d'impact sur le
premier trimestre 2010 21 et très peu
sur le 2e alors certains trouve
formidable que les scientifiques aient
été pris le manche d'autres apprécient
un peu moins écouté ce qu'il faut bien
appeler une forme de pétage de plomb de
renaud muselier c'est le président les
républicains de la région sud et c'était
hier sur france info moi je vous savez
je depuis quelques temps déjà je demande
au conseil scientifique de la ferme et
vingt ans ça suffit le camp ces
scientifiques
voilà j'aurais dû dire le docteur renaud
muselier car je crois qu'il est docteur
en médecine alors ça suffit
conseil scientifique la chartier est ce
que est ce qu'ils ont pris le pouvoir
ses médecins non je pense que c'est un
peu court peut-être deux
on analyse la preuve déjà en est que si
le gouvernement suivait à ce point les
recommandations du conseil scientifique
il aurait durci les mesures à la fin de
l'été parce que le conseil scientifique
demandait au gouvernement de rétablir un
petit peu des mesures coercitives d'eau
crainte d'une deuxième vague
et puis tout simplement lorsque par
exemple les commerces ont rouvert et les
salles de spectacle les cinémas restent
fermées ça n'est pas une décision
salutaire parce qu'il n'y a aucune
raison en fait de fermer les uns et
d'ouvrir les autres en termes sanitaires
les foyers la propagation du virus peut
s'opérer aussi bien dans un endroit que
dans un autre donc on voit bien là que
c'est une décision politique sur le fond
de toute façon je vois mal quand même
comment un gouvernement aujourd'hui de
quelque nationalité soit ils pourraient
s'affranchir entièrement des
recommandations d'un conseil
scientifique vu ce qu'il a en face c'est
à dire c'est une pandémie donc une
question sanitaire
donc non je pense que le gouvernement
est sans arrêt en train de faire un
arbitrage entre des questions et des
impératifs politiques
en l'espèce maintenir une certaine
activité économique et puis tenir compte
des paramètres sanitaires qui sont
évidemment aussi incontournable est-ce
qu'il ya pas eu la veille +5 et abriel
cluzel plusieurs séquences et à dire que
pendant premier confinement surtout au
début
le conseil scientifique était très
écouté par par les autorités publiques
et c'était normal ce qu'on ne
connaissait pas cette pandémie
et puis ensuite le politique a peut-être
repris la main on se souvient qu'au
moment du des confirmands par exemple
conseil scientifique était opposé à la
réouverture des écoles et que emmanuel
macron l'a imposé et que finalement
comment se prend cette deuxième vague
dans la figure et qu'on n'avait pas
forcément prévu et ben les médecins sont
venus au premier plan
c'est à dire que dès le début c'est vrai
que le conseil scientifique a pris une
place prépondérante on va dire le
contraire c'est une crise sanitaire donc
évidemment on a appris des des conseils
médicaux sauf que déjà on s'est rendu
compte que la médecine n'était pas une
science exacte
c'est à la confluence des des sciences
expérimentales et des sciences humaines
finalement et puis c'est presque un art
on voit bien que pour le dire un peu
vulgairement on s'est rendu compte que
le conseil scientifique lui-même et un
certain nombre de médecins au vu des
controverses qui a eu est bien avancé
aussi un peu au doigt mouillé à
l'empirique donc il ya les politiques ne
pouvaient plus se retrancher le
gouvernement de se retrancher de façon
absolue derrière un dogme mais deux fois
scientifique par ailleurs cela
dérangeait ils sont rendus compte je
pense un certain nombre de français qui
se sont dit mais quand il ya la guerre
le chef d'état-major des armées il donne
tous les éléments mais c'est quand même
le président quel bouton nucléaire ou
dans tout cas qui dit on y va on y va
pas donc ils ont été dérangés notamment
le presar salomon cet effet si enfin
tous ces personnages scientifiques qui
ont pris le dessus ont dérangé parce que
les français ont dit mais finalement on
ne les a pas élu et puis on est pas un à
un tous biologique donc là elle est la
vie humaine c'est plus que ça notre vie
c'est plus que cela et donc évidemment
ils ont été remis en cause donc à chaque
fois le gouvernement et tenter de donner
un grand coup de barre et puis il
revient vers ce conseil scientifique
peut-être parce qu'il ya une tentation
que l'on peut comprendre du gouvernement
c'est à dire qu'il se dit de quoi il
sera comptable finalement dans une
société très unie ça risée
et de quoi ils seraient contaminés sera
comptable des effets directs et
immédiats c'est à dire des malades
ducobu disons le concrètement et en
revanche il y aura sans doute des dégâts
on les dit déjà on parle de dépression
de celui-ci depuis le désastre
économique
mais ça c'est plus diffus c'est plus
indirecte ce sera le moyen terme et à
long terme il se joue vrai que le sol
est une honte je pense que c'est une
façon de se couvrir en effet parce que
encore une fois il sera comptable que
deux de ces morts de première ligne si
j'ose dire
et puis c'est peut-être un manque de une
forte depuis juillet limité c'est à dire
que se retrancher derrière le conseil
scientifique ça évite de de choisir et
peut-être de s'exposer à des revers de
bâton plus tard je vous passer la parole
au clair mais je la transmets quelques
instants à nos internautes d'abord pour
montrer que c'était assez partagé le
conseil scientifique prend t-il trop de
place dans les décisions du gouvernement
liée au kobus 19 c'est la question que
nous vous posons sur twitter a acheté un
point de vue c'est oui à 60 %
il ya une majorité réelle mais pas
écrasante et puis à cette question de
christophe sur lefigaro.fr qui est
intéressante et que je vous retransmet
clair ce conseil scientifique est il là
pour conseiller le gouvernement ou pour
communiquer auprès du grand public est
ce que là il n'ya pas du brouillage sur
la ligne avec ses médecins qui sont qui
ont quand même pris goût aux plateaux de
télévision pour faire court
ou alors c'est pas forcément les mêmes
parce que delfraissy il n'est pas comme
ça sur tous les plateaux il ya d'autres
médecins en effet en plus qui sans
paille en direct a fait le show comme on
va dire mais je pense que ce ne sont pas
les mêmes je pense que il ya un déficit
de communication ce gouvernement c'est
pas tant c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de mesures qui passerait certainement
beaucoup pourtant oui mais il est
évident qu'il ya quand même des
explications simples qu'on pourrait
fournir et qui ne sont pas donnés j'en
veux pour exemple juste on a mis un
certain temps à comprendre que certains
lieux étaient fermés pour reprendre les
l'exemple des cinémas des salles de
spectacles kà pas parce que on
considérait la salle entente elle mais
le brassage que ça représentait donc
déjà ne serait ce qui explique et ça
tout simplement ça éviterait déjà pas
mal de polémiques sur pourquoi si
pourquoi ça donc il ya un autre point
qui est vraiment pas tant dans leur
façon de communiquer c'est que et ça
s'était demandée par le conseil
scientifique donc c'est encore un
élément qui montre que le gouvernement
n'ait pas à ce point aligné sur le
conseil scientifique c'est que en fait
les citoyens sont très peu associés à
cette à ces mesures le conseil avait
demandé qu'on mette en place un comité
qui intégrerait des citoyens et rien ne
se passe de ce côté là donc on voit bien
qu'ils sont quand même soumis je pense à
une très forte pression c'est indéniable
et encore une fois tous les exécutifs
leçon c'est essaye de faire sans arrêt
la part des choses et un arbitrage entre
l'économie et la vie parce
qu'effectivement ils seront comptables
in fine et des morts que couzon les
russes et que c'est bien ça c'est
l'horizon final c'est pour ça qu'on ne
peut pas laisser filer cette pandémie
sans rien faire ça n'est pas possible et
ça revient toujours en premier lieu
c'est toujours salle l'impératif
catégorique il faut qu'il faut soutenir
mais je crois qu'il ya un déficit de
communication en revanche je crois pas
du tout à l'idée que le comité
scientifique sera investi 2,7 de ce rôle
là parce qu'en fait ils se débrouillent
pas si bien que ça non plus pense pas
que cela serait une très bonne idée
en tout cas de se reposer sur vu des
résultats
je vous donne la vie de jean marc sur
youtube qui considère que le
gouvernement et le conseil scientifique
sont inefficaces
tous les deux peut-être ajoute-t-il que
le professeur à holt a un ego
surdimensionné mais lui au moins il est
compétent et puis cette réflexion pleine
de sagesse de babineau le conseil
scientifique revient sur le devant de la
scène quand la situation sanitaire se
dégrade
mais c'est le gouvernement qui a le
dernier mot il ya une autre les médecins
les professeurs de médecine qui en font
partie ont des liens qui sont d'ailleurs
déclarés avec des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et du coup il ya cette
7e ce soupçon de conflit d'intérêts est
ce que il vous paraît
justifiée il est évident que c'est un
fait d'ailleurs tous les médecins le
disent elles à tous les échelons si
j'ose dire il y a une forme de
consanguinité d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de laboratoires qui passe dans un
certain nombre de médecins qui passent
dans les laboratoires py qui reviennent
dans la vie de praticiens il y en a même
qui sont dans les milieux politiques et
il est évident que sauf à être d'une
grande naïveté
on voit bien qu'il ya un enjeu
commercial tél au vu de cette pandémie
mondiale qu'on ne peut pas imaginer que
les laboratoires soient complètement
désintéressé et n'essaie pas de faire
pression d'une façon ou d'une autre sur
les médecins alors c'est vrai que je
sais que cette parole là est extrêmement
décrié dès qu'on commence à évoquer ces
sujets là c'est extrêmement glissant
nous dire là vous êtes complotistes non
je crois que c'est tout simplement faire
preuve de 2 comment dirais-je de de
réalisme c'est à dire qu'on imagine bien
qu'il y à une course au vaccin plus
outil qui est et est de ce fait une
tentative d'influencer parce que c'est
légitime c'est légitime
ben c'est à dire que on voit bien que le
comment dire que le conseil scientifique
peut être influencé c'est à dire que
peut avoir les confins l'impact que ça
pourra avoir concrètement sur la les
mesures mariage je pense que moi je
trouve que c'est intéressant de parler
des sujets qui font polémique par
exemple le professeur out
moi je n'ai pas d'avis sur son
traitement en fait n'en est pas ce qu un
internaute on a parlé shrek c'est assez
intéressant
les gens se sont dit lui propose un
traitement sans nécessairement dire
bahia voilà qui propose entraînement
alors qu'on a raison que le conseil
scientifique dima on commencera revivre
à partir du vaccin jamais ils
communiquent réellement sur une
possibilité de traitement alors qu'en
réalité c'est d'ailleurs au delà du
traitement de raout oopad raout on sait
que actuellement ce virus est qu'à mieux
pris en charge c'est-à-dire que les
médecins de façon empirique l'on a peu
apprécié si on s'était dit mme rahout
cette donne rien
non non ce que je dis c'est compliqué
ils y ont été les gens lui ont été
globalement reconnaissant d'émettre
l'idée qu'on pouvait traiter et non pas
d'être dans une espèce de psychose
générale dans l'attenté d'un vaccin qui
jette la suspicion à tort ou à raison
puisque moi j'avoue que j'ai pas les
éléments pour juger mais qui laisse
imaginer que comme il ya cette collusion
qui est connu et qui a toujours existé
et cette consanguinité entre le corps
médical et les laboratoires et qui est
nécessaire du resto faire avancer la
recherche
eh bien il pourrait y avoir ce cette
tentation de pousser vers le vevak les
légitimer effectivement ces liens
existent et c'est là je vois pas trop
très concrètement par rapport à la
position du conseil scientifique par
rapport aux mesures de dire que bon il
faut attendre le vaccin soit je vois pas
forcément le lien direct ainsi à aa a
dit ce prix mais se sentant son rejet
très fort de des thèses du professeur
raoul de ces traitements par rapport aux
procédés ou d'un pack sang je vois pas
fameux paraît naturel de dire attendons
le vaccin tout est propre et ça me
paraît tout à fait on va dire balles
longues comme ont pu le dire un certain
nombre de politiques
certes le vaccin ne sera pas obligatoire
mais si vous n'êtes pas vacciné
vous ne pourrez pas faire ceci ou cela
enfin il ya un certain nombre de
politiques qui ont scellé mieux se
vacciner
non mais le nombre des lignes en magasin
indirect si vous voulez rire l'institut
façon heping logique ça se comprend
parfaitement enfin il ya une vraie
logique indépendamment des liens
d'intérêt avec les labos etc
c'est plus on est nombreux lecteurs
passionnés puisqu'en fait mais c'est
parce que je veux dire c'est à dire que
ce que je veux dire c'est que sur les
mesures dont on parle précisément sans
parler de raul qui est un autre sujet à
mon avis je vois pas là en quoi les
effectivement les liens d'ailleurs ils
sont ils sont mis sur la table c'est bon
la loi et donc on peut tout aléa tout à
fait aller regarder je vois pas
tellement tellement le lien pour finir
sur ce point je pense qu'en fait la
difficulté avec cette dernière petite
polémique
en fait avec le conseil scientifique et
le gouvernement ait suivi le conseil
scientifique sa préférée beaucoup à
l'histoire des enfants qu'on va pas
envoyer à l'école
en fait c'est le premier ministre qui a
dit je trouve que la recommandation du
conseil scientifique elle est
intéressante ne pas envoyer ses enfants
les deux derniers jours bon je pense que
le problème vient beaucoup plus de jean
castex que du comité scientifique en
fait
que cela vient beaucoup plus de sa
maladresse à lui qui est quand même pour
l'instant je suis patente depuis cette
révélation qui savait pas ce que c'était
que le stop président présidence à la
télévision jusqu'au dernier épisode la
plus politique sur le la loi sécurité
globale où il a il a dit qu'une
commission allait réécrire le texte
alors qu'en fait c'est pas une
commission mais c'est au parlement de se
charger de la ddt doit être la star du
net
il avait peut-être passé l'une est ce
que je veux dire c'est que voilà là ce
dernier épisode qui illustre votre sujet
d'aujourd'hui me semble beaucoup plus
renvoyer à bon une forme de je ne sais
pas si je vais être aussi sévère mais en
tout cas si ce n'est de l'incompétence
en tout cas c'est la même console
scientifique qui lui a oui lui a remis
la présence à scientifique a à proposer
plusieurs choses pour le lot il y avait
ça c'était de recommandations disait
isolée vous pendant cinq jours enfin des
choses qui étaient assez encore une fois
assez logique
oui qui sont logiquement nous a dit
cependant pour rouvrir et ouvrir les
écoles que les enfants a priori n'était
pas contagieux voyez le problème c'est
que des mots on aimait des dogmes deux
fois sur lesquels on revient puis un peu
plus tard donc c'est compliqué donc
peut-être que faire preuve de plus
d'humilité et reconnaître que finalement
on sait il n'ya rien qui est gras qui
gravé dans le marbre aujourd'hui et bien
ce serait peut-être être plus
transparent avec les français n'avaient
pour revenir sur cette question des
vaccins pourquoi les ans à une forme de
suspicion chez moi voilà mes et je pense
que si on veut susciter la confiance des
gens il faut être honnête
alors là on l'occurrence est pas le
gouvernement français mais quand
l'europe décide d'acheter des doses de
vaccin
comme le rêve des visites qui ce qui se
révèle dans une étude de jours après
l'achat inopérant eh bien on se dit est
ce que ces sommes non il n'aurait pas
mieux valu les investir dans l'hôpital
et on peut pas on peut s'empêcher de se
demander mais pourquoi cette étude qui
avait été fait avant mais on n'a pas su
avant de prendre la décision d'acheter
pour deux temps deux d'argent et deux
doses de vaccin
pourquoi on n'a pas su avant et se
demander s'il n'y a pas une collusion
d'intérêts c'est normal on peut se dire
qu'il voulait faire effectivement le
mieux possible et avec tous ceux qui s'y
dépose et c'est peut-être une
précipitation parce qu'il fallait agir
au contraire on les presse par ailleurs
de ne pas agir oui mais il faut y voir
non plus preuve non plus n'est lauren
davis s'est révélé être inefficace dans
le traitement de la cop 19e laisse le
dernier mot à nicole sur lefigaro.fr qui
est un peu dubitative et qui me dit le
conseiller scientifique ayant tenu des
propos contradictoires
depuis le début on peut se demander
pourquoi il faudrait le suivre bien
voilà c'est à vous de vous faire votre
propre point de vue
deuxième sujet que je vous propose celui
de la parité assistons à la fable ii
l'arroseuse arrosée anne hidalgo la
maire de paris a été condamné à 90
milles euros damende par le ministère de
la fonction publique parce que en 2018
elle n'avait pas respecté la parité dans
les nominations aux postes de direction
de la mairie de paris
et parce qu'en fait il y avait trop de
femmes voilà et bien
pour ce qui la concerne elle n'en
revient toujours pas écoutez là à parler
de cette histoire c'était au conseil de
paris hier
il y ait une amende pour avoir nommé
trop de femmes aux postes de direction
69% de nomination onze femmes et
seulement cinq hommes et la direction de
la ville seraient tout à coup devenu
beaucoup trop féministe gorille est plus
à l'aise la parité c'est juste alors
mais seulement dans un sens ou est ce
que c'est moi mâles blancs de plus de 50
ans qui veut plein à mauvais escient le
féminisme c'est pas
ça devrait être l'inversé du sexisme
c'est pas un sexisme à l'envers vous
êtes d'accord donc appartement où il ya
une règle et je crois qu'il faut 40 % de
chaque sexe dans la toile à présent à
partir du moment où on a dit et c'est
justifié que chaque les femmes les
hommes apportent chacun leur richesse et
que finalement on s'enrichit à être des
hommes et des femmes dans la même
environnement on peut pas dire tout d'un
coup que c'est pas grave de n'avoir que
des femmes évidemment ça va ça paraît
assez assez évident alors moi vous savez
je suis pas une de toute façon une
grande fan de la politique des quotas je
ne crois pas qu'elles servent les femmes
parce que il ya finalement toujours une
présomption d'incompétents c'est à dire
qu'on se devait ce qu'elle n'est pas là
parce qu'elle est une femme
et ça je trouve que c'est extrêmement
regrettable qu'on ait permis l'accès aux
femmes de tout type d'étude et de
profession et que ce sas est fausse et
c'est tout à fait louable en revanche
qu'on établisse des quotas ou au
contraire ça me paraît assez une
philosophie assez 19e voyez quand on
faisait en inde avec les les hommes
aider les femmes à passer par dessus la
barrière en les enlaidissant balas et un
petit peu pareil on a l'impression que
les femmes peuvent pas se débrouiller si
on leur donne pas un marchepied et pour
ma part je trouve que c'est pas
nécessaire et même assez regrettable
elle est drôle d'histoire quartier quand
même non c'est samantha les abus du
système quand même temps où les excès en
fait je pense si j'ai bien compris la
chose effectivement il ya un problème au
départ c'est que la loi est mal faite et
dallas est en fait la loi a été corrigé
et parce que alors c'est ce que j'ai
compris il ya une loi de transition la
fonction publique doute 2019 qui permet
une dispense de pénalité dans ces cas là
parce qu'en fait pourquoi est-elle mal
faite à la différence des de l'autre loi
qui dit que dans les conseils
d'administration des grandes entreprises
il faut 40 % de femmes
la loi en question d'avant visiblement
ne tenez pas compte de la composition en
fait de la direction enfin du corps
constitués qui était en cause
et donc c'est complètement absurde a
rendu de feu le saut directement à la
coule douce le stock d'eau c'est
complètement absurde
évidemment parce que moi je
je conçois très bien l'argument vous
venez de d'avancé mais je pense aussi
que il ya eu un grand débat au moment de
la loi sur la parité en 2000 pendant les
années 90 c'était assez passionnant
d'ailleurs à suivre mais je pense qu'en
la matière effectivement pour accéder à
l'égalité il faut en passer par un peu
d'inégalités et en l'espèce vraiment
bien d'un point de vue quantitatif la
loi sur la parité a quand même permis un
grand progrès même s'il reste beaucoup à
faire
à grands progrès dans la représentation
des femmes donc pour cette histoire je
pense qu'il qui tient un petit peu quand
même de l'anecdote
ça m'étonnerait d'ailleurs elle s'amuse
jeu ça m'étonnerait que ces pénalités
elles doivent les payer puisque je vous
dis la loi a été un peu corrigé ce que
ce à quoi ça renvoie jal a tellement
endettés la ville que j'aime assez
d'argent pour ce soir parce
qu'évidemment anne hidalgo a l'a bien
fait je veux dire s'il faut savoir d'où
on part et effectivement on part de loin
donc sur le côté contraignant de la
chose pourquoi des quotas il faut quand
même voir qu'en france
alors certes nous avons été le premier
pays à instaurer une loi sur la parité
ça c'est vraiment un fait historique
mais on a essayé aussi un pays qui a
quand même beaucoup attendu avant de
donner aux femmes une certaine
représentation dans l'espace public
vous parliez du 19e au 19e c'est
l'époque de la théorie des deux sphères
qui est ce qu'on fait
postulait que la sphère publique elle
était réservée aux hommes et que la
sphère privée était réservée aux femmes
et on vient aussi d'un pays où quand
même au moment de la révolution
française est bien la révolution n'était
pas extrêmement féministe et une grande
féministe qui ad'ailleurs a fini sur
l'échafaud nizet la femme elle peut
monter sur l'échafaud
elle a aussi également le droit de
monter à la tribune et visiblement
c'était très disputée parce qu'à
l'époque les citoyens de plein exercice
étaient les hommes s'étaient pas les
fables et si les femmes c'était les
citoyennes passif passive donc on vient
de loin et je pense que tout c'est toute
cette culture tout c'est tout cet
héritage il explique qu'aujourd'hui nous
soyons très sensibilisés à ces questions
là et qu'il ya encore beaucoup à faire
mais je trouve ça très salutaire sur
twitter on vous pose la question de la
société va-t-elle trop loin
de parité et c'est oui à 69% je me sens
un peu moins seul du coup réflexion d'un
internaute dont le pseudonyme est one
dream sur youtube le dit quand des
problèmes de discriminations positives
commencent à apparaître pour régler le
problème principal dit-il entre
guillemets je pense qu'on se perd la
politique des quotas est elle fondée
bien c'est la question à laquelle claire
chartier bien essayé de répondre et puis
cette réflexion de nicole sur
lefigaro.fr s'il faut faire de la parité
pour la parité c'est nul il faut choisir
en fonction des compétences je voulais
vous soumettre cette réflexion peut-être
ce cri du coeur de ségolène royal
s'était dans le chez nos confrères du
parisien
elle a déclaré il est temps qu'une femme
soit présidente
alors moi je voudrais vous croyez moi
mon point de vue pour commencer bon moi
j'ai à vous dire maintenant parce que on
vous élire arrêt si vous aussi vous êtes
la meilleure mais cet argument ne me
semble pas opératoire mais peut-être
suis-je minéraux cas sur ce plateau
d'une fort qu'elle ait voté marine le
pen aux dernières élections
malgré son grand désir nouveau président
je pense que son féminisme n'est pas
allé jusque là moi je là aussi je crois
que ça nuit aux femmes du reste c'est
devenu un argument alors là positif
puisque finalement ségolène royal dit
votez pour moi je suis une femme je me
suis un cas ni d'algos disait si on
m'attaque c'est parce que je suis une
femme et il me semble que ceux d'origine
d'un vrai et voilà en plus moi et je
pense que c'est une posture tout à fait
détestable et qui va engendrer des
frustrations et une guerre des sexes qui
ne doit pas avoir lieu parce que
évidemment un homme si à poste égal ou
si au contraire
alors qu'un homme est plus compétent on
va choisir une femme parce qu'elle est
femme c'est ça me semble être un
féminisme extrêmement mal venu moi je
suis pas d'accord avec vous je crois que
une injustice est mauvaise en soi même
pour servir
une bonne bonne cause plus tard je pense
que c'est
c'est extrêmement préjudiciable vous
disait que le 19ème avec un siècle elle
fait ou la femme était pendant lequel
durant laquelle la femme était sous
tutelle c'était moins le cas avant on a
eu des périodes au moyen âge où la femme
était avait une place dans la société
beaucoup plus prégnante est importante
et par ailleurs je je constate
qu'aujourd'hui on en a fait un étendard
de gauche alors que il faut se souvenir
que les femmes ont eu droit à votre robe
ce vote très tardivement elle aurait pu
la voir avant mais il se trouve que la
gauche avait peur qu'elle vote comme
leur curé que les femmes qui étaient
assez pieuse vote comme leur curé donc
elle s'était opposée à ce droit de vote
donc là aussi il faut revenir sur sûr
c'est sur ces notions
alors ce qui m'amuse un peu c'est que je
pense que les hommes politiques qui
court un peu derrière le progrès ont
toujours un train de retard
le prochain train vrai ce féminisme qui
différencie les hommes et les femmes
avec des quotas est qui qui associe le
sexe et le genre c'est un féministe
presque passé presque réactionnaire
maintenant on l'appelle se féminise on
l'appelle féminise sister donc puisque
maintenant sister c'est à dire que vous
associez un sexe est un genre c'est à
dire que moi je suis né avec des
attributs biologique de femmes et je me
considère comme femme
mais si vous demain guillaume vous il ya
des quotas qui s'installe au figaro et
que vous vous dites moi je voudrais
profiter de ce quota pouvez-vous dire
ben jeu en fait je me sens femme voilà
moi y est j'y pense mais voilà j'en
étais sûr et bien il ya des officiers
qui m'ont dit ça en boutade puisque le
ministre des armées
florence parly a dit vouloir un quota
une cohorte de généraux féminin pour je
ne sais plus quelle année ou dans dix
ans une corde importante ils ont dit bon
bah écoute et gk dire que je me sens
femme donc je crois que toutes ces
histoires de quotas elles vont se
heurter à on est tirée par un progrès
toujours plus fous par un féminisme un
peu un peu un peu dingue qui va nous
nous nous force et même là là
revenir là dessus bon moi je crois que
la vraie égalité c2c chacun selon ses
mérites
alors en fait je pense que les quotas
renvoie à une réalité une réalité très
concrète sociale politique qui est
pointée par le haut conseil à l'égalité
entre autres dans les conseils régionaux
départementaux simplement 10 % d'entre
eux sont dirigées par des femmes 20%
pour les conseils régionaux donc ce
n'est pas beaucoup
quatremer sur cinq qui ont des hommes
très souvent c'est par chance y avait
une femme du maire de la deuxième ville
de france et puis en fait les hommes ça
arrange parce qu'il ya des
contournements à cette loi on part été
en politique de plusieurs ficelles
peuvent être employées notamment de
payer finalement lépine et les pénalités
on sait que les partis basques en ce qui
concerne les parties il les paye donc il
ya beaucoup quand même deux choses qui
empêchent les femmes ça c'est là c'est
la réalité qui empêche les femmes
d'accéder ne serait-ce qu quand le quand
ségolène royal dit ça serait bien qu'une
femme soit présidente bien sûr que je la
rejoins pas en revanche ce qu'il faut
c'est que les femmes puissent monter les
toutes ces marches leur permettant de
rivaliser à égalité avec les hommes et
pour l'instant ça n'est pas encore le
cas et c'est pour ça que effectivement
il faut je pense continuer à se dire
qu'une certaine forme de volontarisme
peut avoir un effet de fait quand ça
n'est pas contraignant il n'y a rien qui
se passe c'est absolument observé sûr
que si on n'avait pas eu ces quotas on
en serait resté à une sur représentation
masculine et a une sous-représentation
féminine
parce que encore une fois il ya le réel
parle étant aussi à l'idée de justice
pour reprendre le mot de gabriel plus
est je ne sais pas si c'est une forme
d'injustice pour les obligations
d'organisation sociale je pense que
c'est une question d'organisation
sociale c'est une question aussi
culturelle je pense que plus les femmes
voient que il y à des femmes en
politique elle se débrouille qu'elle y
arrive à conjuguer leur vie personnelle
et leur vie publique
plus elles se disent je peux aussi
galles et donc les quotas s'affaire
aussi à ça ça sert aussi à mettre sur le
sur la place publique ça sert à mettre
dans l'agenda politique des sujets des
sujets qui n'étaient pas traités
auparavant comme le harcèlement sexuel
des sujets qui font partie de du progrès
social a au même titre que d'autres
sujets
sas a plusieurs vertus et encore une
fois la première de ces vertus c'est de
tenir compte du réel et le réel
il est encore encore en faveur mais ce
n'est pas du tout une question de combat
là mais c'est simplement un constat il
est encore bien souvent en faveur de la
représentation masculine
moi je trouve que ces questions
finalement essentialise la femme on dit
que l'on veut lutter contre ça c'était
le mot c'est un mot qui avait plus qu'à
fait plus ou moins d'ailleurs un ventre
et simone de beauvoir
finalement ça s'est moins salée son
calice et là je vous fait mal fait par
exemple la non mais par exemple des
souffrances cécile parent est vrai pour
les nomme parfait on les nomme parce
qu'elles sont femmes n'ont en fait un
homme on s'en fiche de nommer michel ou
nicole on les nomme parce qu'ils sont
compétents voilà et puis deuxièmement
peut-être que peut-être que il faut
sortir de l'idéologie se dire que s'il
ya marchande autant de femmes en
politique que d'hommes c'est peut-être
que les centres d'intérêt sont pas les
mêmes moi ce qui me dérange avec le
féminisme c'est que ça et on connaissait
la servitude volontaire maintenant à la
libération forcé c'est à dire que il y
aurait des métiers il faut il faudrait
que certains métiers qui sont qui sont
masculins soit investir c'est le
challenge endurance mâle donc voilà je
suis complètement d'accord avec vous et
le problème c'est par exemple je pense
aux matières j'entendais certain nombre
de secrétaires d'état féministe dire il
faut que les métiers du btp et de
l'informatique sont exclusives sont
masculins c'est pas bon et si les femmes
ont envie de faire des sons plus en plus
d'appétence pour les victimes
celle inverse ça veut dire qu'il faut à
ce moment-là peut-être donner des leurs
lettres de noblesse aux matières
littéraires mais en revanche pas forcer
les femmes à faire des étincelles n'est
pas nécessairement des factions mais des
quotas
on ne ment pas
non mais par exemple non mais on il ya
une forte incitation dans ces métiers là
et on pousse les jeunes filles et sain
aux annonces faites on essaye de dire
que c'est possible oui mais de ça est ce
que vous connaissez un seul média qui
sont interdits aux far as qu un seul
médecin est interdit aux femmes de citer
mon âme et son chien tueur est donc
celle de la peur son compte voilà aux
hommes vous pouvez aussi être garde
d'enfants mais bien sûr être comment
dire ces soignants d'accoucheur enfin je
veux dire c'est ça le vrai régime
mesdames je pense qu'on ne vous plaira
pas d'accord c'est vraiment je vous le
dis sans sens parce que je le pense tout
ce qui fait l'intérêt de ce débat et de
ceux de cette émission grâce à vous
merci d'avoir été avec nous en 2020
j'espère qu'en vous retrouvera l'année
prochaine en tout cas c'est tout ce
qu'on souhaite et merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis bonsoir
[Musique]